so uh quick uh thing that just came up
recently
um i was asked uh to explain what
are the ways to increase lead quality uh
and so there are
five ways that you can increase lead
quality so this is if you were like man
my leads are weak or i want my leaks to
be higher quality or people are
complaining to you whatever right
there's five ways to do this now that
being said the monetization structure
behind it uh you're going to want to
play with these variables so that you
can optimize your throughput so you can
get the most amount of sales or most
amount of cash up front
depending on whatever it is that you're
optimizing for all right so it's not to
say that you should do all five of these
things because
sometimes you are going to be leaving a
lot of money on the table because
ultimately
you want to remove as few of these are
sorry as many of these as you can
because they're all
bottlenecks on the amount of volume
you're going to get and so each of these
will increase quality but typically
decrease volume
and so these are the trade-offs that
you'll do in the marketing side uh
that these are the variables that you'll
play with in order to get the
the optimal setup for uh for sales all
right so without further ado the five
ways
uh that you can increase lead quality
number one
uh you're targeting all right so the
targeting uh you can do this in a couple
ways one is you can just do it by zip
code other you can do it by
by income level or profession those are
all things that you can do to
immediately
increase lead quality if you go to only
the right zip codes you're going to have
uh you know higher quality leads in
general right that being said
uh if you're doing those zip codes just
understand that other people are also
marketing the zip codes
and they will probably also be more
expensive and your volume would be lower
so there's number one is the targeting
all right number two
is the number of steps that they have to
jump through right if someone has to do
10 steps in order to get on the phone
with you
versus one step they're going to be more
qualified because they took more action
so they're more in pain
and they're more likely to want to uh
work with you right or they were more
compelled by the offer headlines etc
so that will increase the lead quality
as well uh number two
is get started number three excuse me is
the the nature of the offer all right so
a free offer versus a paid offer
uh or a free amazing giveaway uh
compared to a click here to schedule a
sales call
is going to create a very different type
of prospect right not all leads are
created equal and so
if you're having someone opt in for a
giveaway you will have more volume by
a ton um and so that's where there's so
much
emphasis on the monetization structure
behind it the mousetrap that you've
built
in order to like if you have a giveaway
there i know plenty of people in
industry that do giveaways and crush it
because they have a good math trap
behind it and they take advantage of the
volume um but
if you don't do a giveaway and you do a
straight to call then that person is
going to be more qualified than somebody
who
is opting in for just like a giveaway or
whatever right
uh the fourth is going to be an
application right so if you have
application is sort of the same thing as
adding a step but it's
different enough that i figured it was
worth mentioning so you can have like
four pages in a row that only require
one checkbox
uh or you can have one page that has a
lot of questions on it right
and so and the nature of the
applications you have lots of paragraph
question answers it's going to be
more work and therefore a higher quality
lead compared to lots of check boxes
and abc right type questions and answers
for the application
so that's another thing that you can do
to implement
uh to increase the quality of the leads
that are coming through simply adding an
application before they have access to
you
will increase the quality and you can
also there's a lot of psychology behind
the questions that you're asking the
application
so getting them to state their goal
getting them to state that they have a
problem
uh getting to understand what their
biggest unknowns are and the things that
they're struggling with
uh understanding that you know setting
the precedent that there is going to be
an expense are they willing to invest in
you know in a solution for their problem
and if you want to
and have big balls which i would
encourage you to do um put some sort of
minimum amount if you're if you're
if your things you know let's say your
thing's a thousand bucks say hey are you
willing to spend at least 500
on the thing it doesn't mean it has to
be that but at least it gets them in the
ballpark around where you're gonna be
right and then um finally uh the fifth
thing that you can do to increase the
quality of the leads is provide value
first all right so this is gonna be the
actual content of the advertisement
itself
and the video itself so if you have a
video that's incredibly compelling
um but doesn't necessarily
uh explain anything uh or add value to
the consumer
then you might get lots of leads with
the quality and might not be as high
versus a video that might be five
minutes long and provides a tremendous
amount of value
tactical importance that they can
immediately implement their lives uh
then that person uh might be more
qualified if they come in because
they're like you this person has already
provided me value i already know that
they're good at what they do
and so it gives you a more authoritative
positioning um in the prospect's mind
uh so that they uh will be more likely
to give you
money all right so uh there's lots of
ways to increase quality
of the lead the the trade-off and where
you have to come in as a business owner
not just a marketer
is understanding how your business model
works behind it
my two cents on this is that i try and
start with the biggest widest net as
possible and then work backwards
and so what i mean is i just want to get
flow once i get flow then i'm going to
try and create a series of offers and
upsells on that flow that will allow me
to make
more money on the customer because the
worst thing in the world is not having
any flow to begin with and so i would
rather start with
a much wider net and then create a
series of offers
and indoctrination sequences and
pre-frames
that after i get the flow we'll get
someone to give us more money and
typically
if you are good about your sales
engineering
and choreography behind the behind the
opt-in behind the application behind the
call
that's the model itself then you should
know what your numbers are on let's say
a free trial or
somebody who downloads a lead magnet or
whatever it may be
you should know that for every one
dollar i put in here at day 15
i'm at one dollar at day 30 i'm at three
and a half dollars a day 60 i'm at seven
dollars
if you don't have those numbers it will
be much more difficult to make decisions
about your marketing
uh without that and so all that being
said
uh the time to use these five increasing
and quality
uh type applications is when you have so
much volume
and the the quality of the prospects is
so low that you are willing
to sacrifice uh half the throughput or a
third of the throughput
on the advertising to either get a
higher
higher ticket or to accommodate for your
operational capacity right if i can get
let's say i'm booking some sort of
national campaign and i'm going
uh straight to call if my team can't
handle as many and i don't mind
doubling my lead cost to get to put a
fence up
uh because i i can't even handle the
flow that's coming in
then in that instance it would be worth
it for me to double my lead costs
because it doesn't matter
as much to me and i can't handle the
operational flow
but for me personally i tend to start
with the biggest net
and then try and see what i can do on
the back end put the onus or the
responsibility on the model
and the monetization structures in the
sales sequence so that
i can afford whatever i want and then
ultimately have a high volume
high ticket sale or mid ticket sale type
business and
we've rinsed and repeat that exact same
model in
brick and mortar for the gym we've done
it for the supplement company we've done
it for
gym launch we've done it for uh now the
online
uh the online fitness model that we are
getting all of our you know seven-figure
gym owners to walk away from and go into
because they're simply making more money
they're able to get the same average
price point
on these clients as they were before
except they're able to get an unlimited
lead flow and the average the cost per
lead is about a fifth
right and so as long as we can make the
machine behind it work which took us
three or four iterations to get it
really tweaked and continue to do so
put the onus on the model rather than on
the marketing and typically you'll make
more money that's just been my personal
experience and i hopefully
um that provides value for you so
otherwise hope you have an amazing
thursday i hope that gave you five
different ways you can increase lead
quality if you need it
uh for many times though you just need
to look behind the lead at the
monetization system
that they're coming into to make sure
that you can afford the traffic rather
than trying to tweak the front end
so um maybe it was giving you an answer
without giving you an answer
or giving you the five things even
though you might not actually need that
it's usually the model itself
but um if you do have an issue of having
too much traffic and the people aren't
qualified and you're willing
to increase how much you pay per show um
or you don't have the operational
capacity then adding one two three four
five of these qualifiers in
is an easy and fast and reliable way to
increase the quality of the leads coming
in
so otherwise have an amazing day and
i'll catch you guys on the flip side
you